[Musique]
depuis trois ans la promenade masson est
illuminée de toutes parts et ça lui
donne un certain cachet c'est l'une des
artères commerciales avec le plus faible
taux de locaux vacants ville c'est vrai
que par la lumière on peut identifier
d'une manière formidable un territoire
et pour créer une vie de quartier
vibrante ont misé sur l'éclairage
l'installation des traverses lumineuse a
coûté 25 mille dollars
l'idée n'est pas de s'arrêter là c'est
de travailler vraiment sur un programme
mosson en lumière et c'est à dire chaque
année bonifier cet éclairage les
ampoules del et les nouvelles
technologies ont donné un nouveau
souffle à l'éclairage urbain biosphère
pont jacques-cartier stade olympique
la mode est à la mise en lumière à
compter de la semaine prochaine
c'est le clocher de l'uqam qui sera
illuminée à son tour avant tu avais
vraiment que la phase j'irai la face
avant puis là tu vas voir de partout
puis on a fait est qu'on ne faisait la
programmation n'a fait le test de
tourner autour
c'est vraiment le fun la firme
montréalaise du dos qui est en charge du
projet a également travaillé sur
l'illumination du pont jacques-cartier
et sur celle du nouveau radar à café
inauguré l'automne dernier en floride tu
fait flasher une petite lumière là dans
l'espace up l'oeil est tout de suite
attiré pas ça mais aussi dans un espace
qui flashent beaucoup si tu viens tu as
quel mais les lumières bas les gens ici
sont dirigés la lumière un impact un
point énorme sur les âges et donc sur la
perception mais aussi comment les gens
se semblent certains secteurs de la
ville comme le quartier des spectacles
où le vieux montréal ont des politiques
claires en matière d'éclairage
mais ce sont des exceptions il ya très
peu de contrôles présentement montréal /
sur la lumière c'est à dire qu'on n'a
pas vraiment de plan lumière ou de chef
d'orchestre qui dit bah on devrait
éclairer de telle ou telle façon un
manque de vision
peut-être mais d'idées certainement pas
oui on à la créativité à montréal on a
le talent faut juste bien l'exploiter
si on mise sur nos brillants créateurs
et qu'on met en place leur idée
lumineuse c'est peut-être un jour la
ville aux cent clochers qui deviendra la
ville lumière ici mais bien lexandre
chartier radio canada montréal